Happen. The Joe Rogan experience. Yeah.
That's a funny thing with actors, right.
And the billing. Yeah. They want,
they want to make sure that their name is
red first. Well that's, that's, I mean,
you've got to have egos to do these
things. I mean there's so many things.
Need an ego to do them. Yeah. And
then hopefully you can switch,
dial your ego down when you come off
stage. Some people can't do that. Um,
when it comes to billing,
Steve,
if you know about Steve Mcqueen and his
mum was a sort of sometime prostitute
and have man in and out of the house
where the Andy's dad was just never there.
And he found himself through,
uh, a boy's, a boy's retreat,
you know, cause he was breaking the law
and they send them off to this place.
And then they told him to talk
these kids out to train wild horses.
And that was one of the first things
he did. And he was just so ambitious.
And with your Brenner in,
um, in magnificent seven,
because you know, if you know that film
at the beginning, they've got yield.
Brenda, do you know that feeling well?
Was that actually don't remember it. Well,
it's maximums have is a great film,
so it's got Yule Brenner with
his coloring and, but no habits,
such an amazing look.
And Steve Mcqueen at the beginning,
they'd go up to boot hill to bury this
Indian guy up boot hill and people are
not allowing it.
There's racism in the town and they both
go up and they ride shotgun again to
hear us. But he was, he was Yule
Brenner was the top guy. And uh,
finally seem okay. Can you see what
you, you see what Brenda's doing?
You see what his caravan is, ma'am? God,
he's got all this stuff here and he
just wanted to be the top guy. Yeah.
And he got there and it is,
it's a beautiful story. It
doesn't end brilliantly,
but you know, a bullet is
great. Great escape is great.
Yeah. He's a fascinating guy. Steve
McQueen became a race car driver.
Like see? Yeah. Well serious
race card. Yeah, no, he,
he came second and the one
before there's a documentary on,
on the mall, the mall. I used the 24 hour
race and he became, he did a race in, uh,
in America, which was, I
think it was a 12 hour raise,
and they came second with a broken
foot. He did it, and he was just,
he's kind of a force of nature, but
he was also do crazy things. I mean,
really crazy things. We should just
not, we died fairly young to write 50.
He didn't die of cancer. Smoking and
drinking. Yeah. I Dunno know what it was.
How do you know? We still don't know why
people get cancer. My mum died when I,
when I, when I was six, and she
was in this and never smoked.
And she died of bowel cancer. I
mean, what shoes? What is that? Yeah.
Nothing like sentence if,
yeah,
and unless you put in random into the
world. That's my theory of the universe.
[inaudible].